so let's say theoretically you've got
some good rackets going on done some
illegal gun running traffic some drugs
dropped a few banks or jewelry stores
done some insider trading the point is
you're a professional criminal who's
only loyal to one thing the holey dollar
you've got some illegal businesses on
your hands that are doing really well
and now you're literally drowning in
cash great right wrong here's the
problem unless you can show that all
that illegal money came from a
legitimate source like a regular
business for example then you and all
the dirty money that you worked so hard
to make are screwed if you just flat out
and use this dirty money to fund your
lavish lifestyle eventually not
necessarily right away but eventually
you'll catch the attention of those
pesky government agencies like the FBI
IRS DEA and many others but new problems
are a good thing it shows that you've
been taking a fair amount of action but
if you don't continue taking massive
action you're probably gonna end up in
prison for up to a few decades with some
hefty fines we need a way to clean that
money to disguise the nefarious origins
of how we earned it so that we can spend
it on real estate legitimate businesses
and of course to fund the lavish
lifestyle that you rightfully deserve we
need to learn the game of one of the
biggest industries in the world we need
to learn how to be laundryman
money laundering is the lifeblood to our
profession of organized crime without it
there's no point to committing our
crimes in the first place if the money
we get isn't usable and back in the good
old days cleaning the money you got from
the criminal enterprise was pretty easy
since banks get suspicious and have to
report large sums of cash that get
deposited you just sent out a bunch of
renter's also known as Smurfs once the
Smurfs collected the day's cash from
their contacts they'd work their
territory just like door-to-door
salesmen going to different banks in
their area and depositing small sums of
cash but not just any area will do too
small of a town would mean that there
wouldn't be too many banks or customers
and the tellers would be able to
remember faces too big of a city and
there would be long lines making the
Smurfs a lot less efficient so affluent
suburbs ended up being just the right
balance for laundering and what the
simple system alone if each Smurf
deposited just 200 dollars in the 20
accounts each which is very reasonable
to do on one day a mere 10 Smurfs can
allow you to launder 40 thousand dollars
in dirty cash every single day that's
two hundred thousand dollars a week or
ten point four million dollars per year
without raising any eyebrows
but today it's different law enforcement
have realized just how vital
money-laundering is to us and have
severely cracked down on it they're a
lot stricter where banks they've made it
so any business dealing in cash has to
report transactions over $10,000 and
they use algorithms to catch on to
suspicious transactions among other
things and although they've barely made
a dent in the money-laundering world it
does raise the stakes if you get caught
with the punishment being up to thirty
five years or more imprisonment and
fines up to three times the amount
laundered and just like any other
business or industry as the landscape
evolves so do the tactics but the
fundamentals on how to lawn their money
are still the same number one we
obviously want people to not know where
the money came from so we have to
conceal the ownership in the source of
the money number two we want to change
the money's form if you have three
million dollars and $20 bills to wash
you don't want to end up with the same
three million dollars in $20 bills you
want to consolidate that three million
dollars into say $100 bills this reduces
the bulk and helps conceal the origin of
it at the same time
number three money laundering doesn't
work if a nosy detective can just follow
the trail of money right back to you so
we have to obscure the trail and lastly
number four dealing with tons of cash
requires a ton of manpower and the more
the man powered the more opportunities
for people to skim off your cash and
since you can't just call the police or
sue someone if they stole dirty money
from you you have to have complete
control over the process and the people
so now that you know the fundamentals of
laundering let's get into the actual
wash
before we can make dirty money look as
if it came from a clean source we have
to get the dirty money into the banking
system in the first place since we're at
the beginning of the money trail this is
where we're most vulnerable and when
you're dealing with a lot of cash one of
the most popular ways to go about doing
this is by using legitimate businesses
as fronts for your laundering it's
probably why a lot of hole-in-the-wall
restaurants and drug trafficking areas
like South Florida or New York only
accept cash the goal with fronts is for
legitimate customers to walk in and out
of the front door while dirty money
sneaks in from the back by a restaurant
bar a retail store or any other business
that deals a lot in cash and carefully
inject a little extra cash into the
business's books every single day if you
do this gradually it will be next to
impossible to spot an extra $500 coming
in daily for a restaurant that caters to
hundreds of customers a day that's a
hundred eighty two thousand five hundred
dollars a year of dirty money now all of
a sudden looks like it came from your
legitimate business people also wouldn't
raise any eyebrows if you eventually
scaled up to let's say ten restaurants
that all happen to have five hundred
dollars added to it every single day at
that scale that's one point eight
million dollars every single year and
safe clean money going into your pocket
now before you get too excited this is
usually the part where laundry men get
into trouble they'll think to themselves
oh if I just Nikken six hundred dollars
a day instead of five hundred how can an
extra thirty six thousand five hundred
dollars each year from each fronts then
that $600 a day turns into $1,000 a day
and then ten thousand dollars a day and
then you try to get your local banker in
on the scheme and then prison large sums
the companies like Southern Air
Transport that raises the feds antennae
it looks like one big money laundering
machine and that's not what you want
that's no bueno smaller sums with more
frequent deposits through my company's
fly right under the radar of the feds
you know why
because all of my companies are
legitimate greed is what will attract
the wrong attention greed is what will
get you killed in this game so don't get
greedy
keep it gradual and let's move on to
step number two of the wash after Dirty
Money is brought into the financial
system it's time to hose off all that
blood with some heavy soaping this is
where all of our work has been leading
up to making our illegal money look like
it came from a legal source and the way
we do this is by sending the dirty money
through as many accounts as possible in
our restaurant example this is as simple
as jacking up the receipts of what
customers paid so that the dirty money
is hidden into the customer's
transactions to make it look like it
came from Lum if you need to launder
lots of money it gets a little bit more
complicated but all it really entails is
setting up a bunch of dummy companies
around the world in areas where the
economy is stable and they don't enforce
money laundering as heavily this is as
simple as literally grueling shell
companies for sale make sure your name
isn't on any of them of course send fake
invoices from one of your companies to
the account your dirty money is in wire
lap money to that particular shell
company and then repeat this process of
sending money around the world to as
many different accounts as you please
since you chose areas where banks have a
lot more secrecy and don't have to
disclose as much about their clients a
meddling detective trying to follow the
money back to you will be out of luck
and once you've successfully obscured
the trail leading back to you it's time
for the fun part
and just like that by loading dirty
money into the financial system and
hosing out all that blood by sending the
money through a series of hard to follow
transactions we've concealed the illegal
origin of it we've changed the money's
form we've obscured the trail leading
back to us and all the while maintaining
complete control over the entire process
and now it's time for the moment you've
been waiting for withdrawing that newly
wash money from their accounts back into
circulation as sweet taxable and most
importantly legal income that you can
spend on whatever your heart desires and
if you did your job right those vultures
and law enforcement won't be able to do
anything about it even if they're
suspicious simply because they can't
trace the money back to you now as your
fiduciary I am compelled to give you
this warning since this is an
underground illegal business
laundry men aren't too keen on sharing
their tips and secrets with the public
so everything we went over in this video
is based on what law enforcement has
found or in other words it's based
solely on the people who've already been
caught so if you have the hopes of being
a successful laundry man you better
innovate and not just copy what everyone
else has done or else you'll end up with
the same fate prison and fines society
is also gradually getting more and more
cashless and although cash won't be
going anywhere for a while crypto
currencies have already taken over the
criminal world by storm now though
they're not anonymous a hundred percent
of the time it sure does make the job of
an inspiring laundry man a lot easier
with the law enforcement world's still
struggling to catch up but whatever it
direction the world of currency goes the
basics of laundering will always stay
the same making illegal money look legal
welcome to the watch the egg Club if
you're watching this right now you guys
are my most loyal supporters and if you
are new to this channel I make video
essays like this every single week on
the most provocative stuff in the world
business so if you enjoyed this one well
you're probably gonna enjoy the future
ones so click that red subscribe button
below and turn the notification bell
because it's free and you can dislike
and unsub and leave me your best hate
comments whenever you want if you wanted
to support this channel financially
being that you're probably stuck at home
right now for obvious reasons you might
as well take advantage of
extra time by checking out a course I
made on how to land a remote job and
work from home that is how I got my
start with this whole make money online
thing with a $40 per hour web dev job
and I think it's the most practical path
out there plus with a remote job you'll
be fine in situations like this and you
get to support this channel financially
at the same time there's a very big very
temporary sale going on right now and I
will link it in the video description
that is all the shameless plugs I have
for you guys thank you so much for
watching I mean that from my heart
you've been awesome
I've been Jake I'll see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
you